à presque 32 ans il se lance dans sa
deuxième campagne des élections
municipales à trappes
en 2014 le conseiller d'opposition
othman nassr où était arrivé en deuxième
position avec 30 % des voix en
s'appuyant déjà à l'époque sur son
association trappe citoyens cet attrape
que j'ai démarré mon engagement
politique que j'ai pris des
responsabilités politiques importantes
depuis l agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines à la région ile de france
mais que c'est ici que ça a commencé que
sept trappistes que je le dois
j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui avec cette
expérience que j'ai pu acquérir de
pouvoir être utile priorité absolue pour
lui attrape l'éducation et la réussite
scolaires pour bâtir son projet celui
qui est vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines et élu régional dans des
majorités de droite entend proposer pour
les municipales une liste rassemblant
diverses sensibilités politiques
à ses côtés pour annoncer sa candidature
ça mieux labo ancien membre de la
majorité du maire divers gauche de
trappes qui vient de rejoindre
l'opposition
le temps des étiquettes des appareils il
n'est pas devant nous il plutôt derrière
long par contre aujourd'hui c'est le
temps du local des idées des projets et
c'est ça que j'ai envie de porter aussi
comme je le fais depuis 2014 mais d'une
manière maintenant qu'ils soient
parfaitement claires et parfaitement
audible avec le rassemblement le plus
large
d'autres candidats se sont fait
connaître attrape le maire sortant guy
malandain seront en lice pour un
quatrième mandat
mustapha larbaoui s'est lui aussi lancé
dans la campagne reste à déterminer s'il
sera tête de liste ou simple colistiers